s'inquiète pour sa 17e siècle années
qu'on vient de vivre a été tellement
particulière est elle une hystérie
médiatique sanitaires aussi un peu mais
aussi médiatique sur ce confinement d'où
le titre infiniment confinement que
j'avais envie il ya très longtemps que
j'ai pas sorti un bouquin ça fait 6 ou 7
ans et j'avais vraiment envie de me suis
dit là c'est l'occasion de le faire
élire ce qui s'est passé effectivement
depuis la fameuse photo puisque on en
reparlera depuis vendredi soir puisque
la sueur a été enregistrée vendredi
prouve bien qu'il ya une hystérie autour
de autour de tout ça qui sait regarder
une nuée de sang soit moi je vais te
dire hier j'ai reçu 10 appelle le truc
demain c est laurent ruquier ça va être
énorme
il y aura pas ou y aura aucun maxime
alliés sur les radios la caisse espaces
bon je suis en train de jouer au pad je
m'en foutais un peu
mais si je peux dire un mot là-dessus
parce que quand même c'est que depuis ce
matin on n'arrête pas de lire que le
ster l'émission qui aurait contaminé là
au moment où je vous parle on est en
direct la grille au moment où je vous
parle il ya personne parmi toutes les
personnes qui étaient sur ce plateau qui
ont été contaminés sur notre plateau
alors d'abord main je fais de la
télévision vous savez aux enfants de la
télé une émission en direct tous les
samedis soirs je fais les grosses têtes
ça tout ça depuis plus d'un an sans que
jamais il ya eu un seul conca contact
sur les plateaux télé ni à la radio
c'est déjà je voulais dire ça et à
france télévisions et flip qu il est le
producteur fait tout ce qu'il faut pour
que les conditions sanitaires et
hygiéniques soit respectée et la
distanciation et tout ce qu'on sait la
tuque ce qui nous est arrivé peut
arriver ici n'importe où l'on va on
verra d'abord de qui non mais je
voudrais le dire parce que moi je veux
pas dire qui parce que c'est pas à moi
de faire un sortie ccsa fait partie du
secret médical je sais que c'est sorti
mais le regarde mais en tout cas c'est
quelqu'un parmi les trente invités qui
est arrivé sur le plateau qui ne savait
pas qu'il était contaminé mais qui a été
contaminé mercredi ou jeudi 5 et un
temps de délai entre le moment où on est
contaminé et le moment où on ne sait et
surtout en plus
on le sait parfois trop table est venu
il est venu à cette émission sans le
savoir
donc il n'y est pour rien le pauvre et
nous non plus on n'y est pour rien on
n'a pas sonné a contaminé personne c'est
quelqu'un qui est arrivés contaminés sur
le plateau on va bourrer à poil et
surtout attendait surtout ce qu'il faut
dire qu'en dessous il balança d'appui
motion va très bien surtout c'est ça
qu'il faut dire qu'il est là cette
dictature de l'apport de du sensationnel
et tout le monde va très bien la
personne en question vin très bien c'est
des symptô minimes et voilà et quant aux
autres matinalier c'est par sécurité ou
par tel que certaines stations leur ont
demandé de faire de faire leur journal
depuis cessé depuis chez eux mais je
sais que pascal praud a fait ses
émissions sur la photo jean jacques
bourdin a fait ses émissions il est sur
la photo julien courbet a fait ses
émissions il est sur la photo
et quant aux autres vous le savez
puisque c'était un hommage aux grandes
voix de la radio on la sait pas et mon
la plupart y sont septuagénaires voire
des octogénaires et donc doublement
vacciner il n'y avait donc aucun risque
pour eux pas merci
je crois que j'ai dit l'essentiel c'est
vrai voir revenir 2 audrey ce que c'est
vrai que juste ce matin tous les
matinales y est survenu sur le cluster
de samedi soir parce que vous fêtiez les
chantant de la radio thuram était de
nombreuses figures de la radio problème
yves calvi qui étaient présents ensuite
été testés positifs au co vide et yvan
plus il a fallu que ça tombe sur notre
groupe au jour surtout que ça tombe du
coup donc ça a perturbé complètement les
radios aujourd'hui parce que toutes les
personnes présentes étaient qu'à
contacter alors on va vous dire qui
s'est confiné qui est allé bosser alors
déjà regardé yves calvi à qui il a parlé
pendant la nation on a fait le parcours
est difficle regarde très con moi j'ai
jamais pratiquer mon métier en étant une
femme et on va faire une fois que tout
ça soit pour marquer le coup quand même
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors gilles das vacciner marco je ne
sais pas georges lang doublement
vacciner julien courbet s'est fait
tester ce matin c'est pour ça qu'il
allait faire ses émissions pascal
lesellier julie vacciner voilà la
plupart étaient vaccinés évidemment ça
alors alors je vais dire cela mais
n'étaient pas vaccinés voilà peut-être
c'est ce à quoi elle est restée chez
elle certains tong ont voulu pas du tout
mais pas du tout puisque vous pas être
qu'à broder tous cas qu'on est bien sûr
un peut arriver n'importe où y avait
rien de dramatique dans cette affaire
franchement personne n'ait à l'hôpital
tout le monde va bien personne n'a
raison qu'on va la manger sur le plateau
je le redis j'ai pas vraiment castaldi
qui était qu un contact ce week-end moi
je dis restez il aurait été juste pour
des raisons bien sûr pécuniaire à voir
avec ce que vous connaissez voilà ça n'a
rien à voir
alors donc on a vu ce matin et on va
miner machina n'y en a pas mal qui ont
parlé ce matin julien courbet qui s'est
permis de faire une petite vanne de plus
j'imagine alors regardez nous saluons
nous accueillons julien courbet bonjour
ça va j'ai rome marie bien vous ne
partez pas tout de suite j'espère n'ont
pas ce qu'on va faire une grande photo
de famille d'animateurs d'intel a laissé
très à la mode faire des photos de
groupe en soit je tiens à préciser je
suis vacciné je me suis dit et si c'est
maintenant tout va bien merci à vous ils
comprendront bas ces écoutes à faux la
radio mondiale et donc qui est restée
chez elle
jean luc bourdon a voulu rassurer tout
le monde alors qu'il était en phase de
gérald darmanin il est vacciné comme
vous avez dit est ce que laurent juste
ça vous étonne
ce buzz que sa fille amy parce que fanon
ça ne m'étonne pas au fond parce que ce
que je raconte dans le bouquin c'est
exactement ça c'est cette hystérie
autour autour du cou ville de kobe à
tuer trop trop trop de gens trop de
personnes plus de cent mille personnes
en france depuis plus d'un an futur
rappeler que c'est depuis plus d'un an
maintenant parce que on accumule les
morts comme ça comme s'ils ne sont pas
les seuls mais c'est le dirigeant
l'instant mais voilà il n'en reste pas
mois que le coc vite touche 0,016 s'ils
voulaient 0,016 % de français qui sont
hors du coup vite donc je veux dire sur
faut rappeler les chiffres tels qu'ils
sont ça c'est la vérité c'est un chiffre
on ne peut pas le contester 0,16 % des
français ne veut pas tout à l'heure les
0,7 pour cent des français qui sont mort
du co vide cetc je prie évidemment que
je voudrais pas être contredit mais
normalement personne ne va mourir du coc
vite je tiens à rassurer tout le monde
sur cette photo et personne ne sera
contaminé en tout cas à l'heure où je
parle personne n'a été contaminé sur
notre plateau je sais que c'est surtout
votre producteur aussi un fille juillet
que nos producteurs
mr bonnal cette photo est formidable
trois personnes ne regrette de l'avoir
fait cette photo et des photos si à
parfumer à comberlin
j'en ai vu ne tient sur d'autres chaînes
sur tf1 samedi soir il y avait tous les
candidats de the voice avec tous les
membres du jury
personne ne leur dit rien aux prénoms
mais ça va quoi y'a un moment il faut
aussi apprendre à revivre je vous
signale que dans 9 jours va aller voir
les français normalement terrassera
insurgés ils vont manger en terrasse
alors ça veut dire quoi on va au bout de
huit jours refermez tout par sa maman
doit être qu'à contact d'un cas contacts
qu est-ce qu on est chez les fous
l'ordre